relatively insignificant viruses
responsible for about fifteen to thirty
percent of the common colds that
essentially each and every one of us in
this room experience every year but what
happened is in 2002 coronaviruses which
also have an animal reservoir
particularly among bats and other
animals actually jumped species and we
proved it retrospectively that it jumped
from a bat to what we call a civet cat
which is an animal that is served at
best at least particularly in China then
it jumped from the bat to a civet cat to
a human leading to the disease between
now Noah SARS
the the severe acute respiratory
syndrome there are 8,000 people and
about 775 deaths for a death rate of
about nine to ten percent then about
twelve years later when we got to 2012
what we had was the Middle East
respiratory syndrome another corona
virus this one with a with a death rate
of about 36% and lo and behold now in
2019 into 2010 to 2020 we have a new
novel coronavirus
the likelihood that this did the same
pattern of jumping species is almost
certain we don't know exactly what the
intermediate host was so we're dealing
with now something that's unique and
troublesome as we've seen the havoc that
has been wrenched in in the air in China
with the number of cases they've had is
that this virus has adapted itself
extremely well the transmissibility in
humans some viruses when they jump
species can be deadly but they're very
poorly adapted to humans this one has
the capability of spreading readily from
human to human it results in a pulmonary
disease in those who have serious
disease the death rate or we call the
case fatality rate is about two percent
2.5 percent whether that's the most
accurate we don't know because
is conceivable that there are enough
people who are below the threshold of
detected symptoms so that the
denominator that equation might be
larger
hence the death rate may be less but
even that is a serious case fatality
rate because seasonal influenza has a
case fatality rate of 0.1% so therefore
you have somewhat of a serious potential
for morbidity and mortality so right now
what we're seeing is that we're seeing
this spreading through multiple
countries that you can hear a bit about
from dr. sugar what we need to do now
obviously is the containment as well as
if it comes to that the mitigation of
the effect of this symma dealing with a
serious virus that we're taking very
seriously because of its potential so
I'll stop there and another can you
clarify who is in charge of the task
force is it you or is it secretary a
czar the president has asked me to lead
our administration's after it in
response with coronavirus are you
leading the task force I'm leading the
task force will continue to rely on the
Secretary's role as chairman of the task
force and the leader of Health and Human
Services but we've known each other for
many years and work together very
closely over the years and
has every confidence in the secretary as
I do but president wanted to make the
American people that we're going to
bring the whole of government approach
for this president wanted to make it
clear that what a priority this is for
him and for our administration to that
end I also spoke today and last night
with the Republican and Democrat
leadership of the House and Senate we're
already beginning discussions over an
additional supplemental bill will be
leaning on the task force for guidance
but those were productive conversations
are very positive this is the time when
the president said we want all hands on
deck and my role is to help lead this
effort with the White House command task
force but also engage our governor's
engage local officials including mayor's
around the country and work with members
of Congress on Capitol Hill to make sure
that all the agencies represented here
in our state and local partners have the
resources there
[Music]
so we started the story as looking into
the organization our efforts continue
apace we are continually engaging with
host governments in the asia-pacific
region to ensure they are informed of
our policies and that we can share
information and best practices to
address this outbreak we successfully
encouraged Beijing to accept us experts
in the w-h-o mission to China On
February 7 2020 the United States
government announced that it is prepared
to provide up to 100 million dollars in
existing funds to assist countries
including China impacted by and at risk
from the virus assistance to contain and
combat kovat 19 will be provided
bilaterally and through multilateral
organizations this commitment along with
the hundreds of millions generously
donated by the American private sector
demonstrates strong US leadership in
response to the outbreak thank you mr.
Chairman I look forward to answering
your questions and those of other
members of the subcommittee Thank You
mr. Fritz mr. Brownlee